[Music]
lisa is starting off this particular
hour and idaho hi Lisa welcome to Dave
Ramsey show
hi mr. Ramsey I'm a huge fan I was I was
raised in a household without debt and
I've pretty much lived my whole life
without dead and I'm thankful I took FPU
just to make sure I didn't get tempted
into starting some debt but I'm in a
really strange situation right now a
little background information but a year
and a half ago my ex-husband called and
said that his company was switching to
an out of house payroll company so my
payments would be slightly different
they would be every other week instead
of twice a month and so some months I
would get three payments and shortly
after this new out of house payroll
company took over they just they kept
screwing things up I couldn't get
anybody to respond to my phone calls
finally I had to get health and welfare
involved several months went by I was
just erratic payments as they tried to
figure it out and get things caught up
well in the meantime I got engaged and
my budget was changed between wedding
expenses paying for all those with cash
and then my fiancee helping with some of
my regular bills like just wasn't paying
as close of attention as I should have
and last month after the wedding I was
all proud of her for paying for the
whole wedding with cash and not having
any debt I sat down and I looked and I
noticed that I've been getting too many
payments too many too many child support
payments so I notified my ex-husband and
his company swears they're paying the
right amount and they're taking the
right amount out and they're not doing
anything wrong but I've literally been
overpaid around $8,000 and at some point
somebody's going to come asking me for
this money back and so I wanted your
advice as far as you know how do I
prepare myself for this I thought how
are you calculating you've been overpaid
$8,000 in just a matter of months and
how in the world could that happen and
you not notice well
$800 you might not notice $8,000
well I discussing with a $30,000 wedding
and like I said my dollars turning up
most people wouldn't notice yeah yeah
you would think but it was like $600
one month or $1,000 the next month and
we were just sending money out left and
right so I kind of was at the point
where just checking to make sure I had
money in my account but money in my
account I was good to go I was how much
30 a month he's supposed to pay two
payments of 628 dollars okay so he's
supposed to pay 1,250 bucks a month
roughly yeah mm-hmm and you have
received how much a month well it's it's
very sporadic so I printed out the total
history and I noticed the first occasion
of it was well in July of last year
there were no payments and then in
August there were five payments and so
I'm like okay well they're getting
caught up and then in September there
was one payment October two payments
November three payments December two
payments then January there were four
payments and I didn't notice that extra
payment in January
these people are avenged they I can't
believe it I mean and then in March
there were five payments so it was so
small attic like I said I was just
checking to make sure there was money in
the account paying bills for the wedding
I wasn't paying attention
I just wasn't I honestly just wasn't
paying it was a prayer well listening so
where's the money have you set it aside
well I was spending it yeah but I have I
mean but I had kept $8,000 in savings
for our honeymoon we were gonna take a
honeymoon next year so I have them I
have $8,000 so if they say you gotta pay
me back right now I have the money but
that's my honeymoon fund so I'm kind of
like well it's not really my fault that
they over so it is you haven't been
keeping up with it right your head in
the sand of course it's your fault
they're screw-ups but you weren't even
even know $8,000 too much came in to
your household yeah over the course of a
year attention to your freaking stuff I
mean you really had your head in the
sand you were not doing a budget they
were not managing money you didn't have
a clue I was in the process of getting
married I was very distracted and was
the hours a week so this is your fault
if I had money okay now what
how do I pay this [ __ ] I mean do I just
empty out my savings and no I wouldn't I
wouldn't empty it out I mean I was just
but over a course of the next few months
I would be making sure I had the right
amount and for that for God's sake start
tracking it now so let's say this
happens okay you go on your honeymoon
you come home but you build up $8,000 to
be able to pay them back you print out
the spreadsheet that shows that you owe
them $8,000 you send it to your husband
you send it to the goofballs that cannot
seem to get out two checks a month I
don't know why that's difficult and you
know we're go ahead and send it to
health and welfare and go I owe you
$8,000 look at this look at this
freaking sheet I mean it's sixth-grade
math if somebody in this entire story
would bother to freaking pay attention
one of you people between you and this
ridiculous payroll company or your
husband ex-husband could actually figure
out that this is not right
then we can just transfer the money back
over to where it should be or you can
give him a credit and he doesn't have to
pay you for a while which would be even
better just do that to say I'm not gonna
pay you back but you don't have to pay
me for a while until we get caught Patil
you tell I get caught back up with you
and she but you guys all got to start
paying attention it's time for all of
you to be grownups